renya oui karim nous sommes aux
cinquante quatrième jour de l'offensive
les russes continuent de faire régner la
terreur par les airs et ce quelle que
soit la région du pays c'est cela
quelle que soit la région du pays
aujourd'hui on en a la démonstration
puisque à l'est le vivat été touché
pardon ni pro a été touché à l'ouest le
vivat été touché et il y a régulièrement
des frappes sur l'ensemble du pays alors
du côté denis pro nous nous trouvons
cinq missiles ont frappé la région
notamment du côté de pavlo rade des
infrastructures ont été touchés des
infrastructures ferroviaires notamment
du côté des autorités régionales denis
proulx on explique que 60% à des frappes
russes ont été interceptés mais un
certain nombre ont tout de même touché
la région vous avez évoqué le cas de
lviv où plusieurs missiles sont tombés
trois missiles ont frappé des objectifs
militaires mais il y aurait selon le
maire de lviv un hôtel qui ont été
touchés de plein fouet de nombreux
véhicules une quarantaine de véhicules
détruits ou abîmés vous avez évoqué ce
bilan de plusieurs morts dont un enfant
semble-t-il et le nombre de blessés
semble augmenter donc la pression russe
s'accroît en tout cas en ce début de
semaine les frappes sont sont nombreuses
d'est en ouest
denis pro jusqu'à lviv mais également du
côté de kiev où les russes semblent
frapper de plus en plus alors on a le
sentiment que c'est peut-être la
préparation d'une offensive plus large
qui semble se mettre en place avec la
recrudescence de ces frappes en tout cas
du côté du donbass et du nord du donbass
ce matin il y avait une offensive russe
du côté de crémines hasni palois de
severodonetsk une ville qui est sous le
feu russe depuis plusieurs jours les
autorités de la région de l'ours qu'ont
expliqué qu'il était totalement
impossible d'évacuer les civils dans la
zone
karim vous qui évoluez ces derniers
joueront aux côtés de mohamed farah
petit vous accompagne vous avez
rencontré c'est c'est l'ukrainien
particulièrement déterminé à l'heure où
l'on annonce cette offensive imminente
sur le dombass vous ne pouvait que
constater cette forte mobilisation des
civils des ukrainiens
alors je peux vous parler de la façon
dont ça se passe ici à denis pro et
c'est un endroit stratégique puisque on
se trouve finalement au carrefour de
plusieurs fronts heures kharkiv au nord
le dombass à l'est carson qui a été
frappée d'ailleurs aujourd'hui au sud
est ici et bien il y a cinquante mille
personnes qui sont partis sous les
drapeaux pour être présent sur le front
et puis c'est une base arrière en
quelque sorte où il ya énormément de
civils qui se sont mobilisés des civils
de toutes les franges de la société pour
apporter en quelque sorte leur pierre à
l'édifice il participe à aller chercher
des civils qui sont coincés dans les
zones sous le feu russe lorsque les bus
ou les trains ne peuvent pas se déplacer
c'est des petits véhicules individuels
qui partent chercher des civils il leur
faut pas revenir aussi des produits de
première nécessité une participants
quelque sorte à l'effort de guerre en
fournissant aussi des produits pour les
militaires notamment des gilets de
protection des gilets pare balles ou
encore des trousses médicales
essentiellement pour les faire parvenir
à ces à ces civils qui ont pris les
armes qui ne sont pas des militaires
professionnels
cette défense territoriale qui depuis
cinquante jours est en train d'apprendre
le maniement des armes en quelque sorte
et tout ce qu'on a croisés nous ont
expliqué que ces 50 jours il avait tenté
de les mettre à profit pour être prêt
pour la grande offensive qui est attendu
déjà depuis quelques semaines par les
autorités ukrainiennes